hey there everybody welcome to this
week's edition of ask a career coach my
name is Martin McGovern and this week
we're gonna be diving into the topic of
motivation how can you stay motivated
during the ups and downs and the pretty
crazy rollercoaster that is your job
search as we wait for people to join
we're gonna give about five minutes for
folks to join the group join the live
stream it's you know give us a shout in
the chat where are you joining us from
today what time is it by you and he's a
crazy stormy day a beautiful sunny day
or somewhere in between like Chicago
over here excited to see where you're
joining us from and if you have
questions already on your mind about the
job search don't be afraid to put them
in the chat we've got Karen there she'll
be passing along all of your questions
to me and we'll be digging into each one
of them over the next hour so thank you
all for joining us for anyone who is a
returning viewer thank you so much for
coming back I'm sure that there's lots
of questions that our previous
conversations stirred up and hopefully
we'll be able to answer those today and
if you're new here the way that this
works is we kick off the conversation
today with one topic and today's topic
is how do you stay motivated and I'm
gonna give a little bit of a spiel on
that and then as I'm doing that you can
start digging into your you know gray
matter and figuring out what sort of
questions you got that you want to ask
put those in the chat they'll be passed
along to me and I'll be digging into
each one of your questions throughout
the hour so thank you again for joining
us we're gonna give it just a few
minutes for folks to jump on the
livestream and let's see where y'all
joining us from all right Hamburg making
me hungry for lunch with hamburgers the
UK Italy Egypt
when do any of you have tips on staying
motivated what has helped you out
throughout your job search or maybe even
just through your nano degree program
what has helped you stay motivated
we got Dallas Texas San Jose New York
City Phoenix it's gonna be 85 and hot as
a cactus out there is it a nice emoji
welcome back some folks Belgium Egypt
Idaho we got another Egypt Saudi let's
see here
India and Syria lots of coffee I love
that I've had lots of coffee today as
well alright we got folks coming in from
Greece we're gonna give it just another
minute for folks to join the chat we've
got a good turnout today so I'm excited
to hear your questions if you've already
got your questions ready don't hesitate
start clicking away at that at that key
back keypad and letting us know what's
on your mind all right well thank you
all so much for joining us today
my name is Martin McGovern and I'm a
career coach here at Udacity my
background is in marketing so I'm here
to help you with both the promotional
and emotional side of your job search
and what we're gonna be doing is gonna
be diving into all of your questions
whether it's how to be confident and
motivated during an interview during a
Tech interview during writing your cover
letters updating your resume creating
projects getting out there and
volunteering finding side hustles all
the different things that you can do to
build a great career and succeed in your
job search that's what we're gonna be
diving into today so don't hesitate to
bring your questions and really lay them
out because we can dive into all of them
some things might be a little too
technical for me if you get really into
the weeds since I'm not a programmer but
don't worry for the most part I can at
least reference the majority of the
things that come up during these q and
A's and if we don't have an answer for
you today will direct you to the place
that you need to go to learn a little
bit more so thank you so much for
joining
and we'll be diving into our first
question right about now all right how
do i how can i sorry let me try that
again
how can i stay motivated in the job
search this is probably the toughest
part of finding a job for most people
finding a job is really quite a
rollercoaster you have some really high
highs whenever you start getting those
interviews or start hearing back going
on that first second third round and
then we have really low lows maybe
you've gone to two or three rounds of
interviews and you didn't get that
position and you fall into what is
colloquially known as the trough of
despair right and what ends up happening
a lot of times when folks are searching
for jobs is they focused very very
strongly on one opportunity rather than
trying to keep lots of things moving as
they go through their search so what
ends up happening is they get traction
with one they let everything else fall
off they keep moving forward they're not
applying to new things not networking
not finding new people and then if they
don't get that role they're back at zero
and so a big piece of keeping your
motivation up is just to keep the
activities moving even if you're
interviewing even if you feel like this
is going to be the one because you
really never know with the job search so
you got to keep lots of things moving
forward at all times in order to keep
yourself sort of even keel throughout
rather than having these real high peaks
and real low valleys so that's one thing
to keep in mind when trying to stay
motivated during the job search the
other thing to keep in mind is to have a
plan having a plan is key when we don't
have a plan we're just running in every
direction right we're standing on a road
and it just Forks off everywhere you can
go in so many different paths you could
go to this industry or that industry or
this title or that title or this city or
that city it's too overwhelming the
difference between a sort of jaggedy
uphill move to the top of the mountain
or a roller coaster that just starts
back at the beginning
a plan so if you're on this roller
coaster you're just chasing everything
that comes your way LinkedIn sends you
an email and says here's the new jobs in
your area you apply to those things you
really don't know what they are you
didn't spend much time researching them
and you're just kind of spinning your
wheels but if you have a goal if you
have a very specific place that you want
to get at the end of this job search I
want to work in this city in this
industry doing this type of a job we can
get you to that top of the mountain and
it might be a little bit of a windy path
that might have a couple detours but
you'll get there and you'll or you'll
figure out what it is that you need to
change in order to achieve your goal at
the end so we really want you to have
that really strong goal at the end of
the the job search and if you really
figure that out and you know just dive
in what is the industry you want working
what is the specific job title that you
want to have not a myriad of five or ten
and you know what industries interest
you the most if you have those basic
three things down you'll be in a much
better place than most people who are
just kind of reactionary and waiting for
indeed to send them that perfect
position because when indeed sending out
those emails there's a lot of
competition for those positions because
they're sending out to a lot of
different people so you know we want to
be proactive rather than reactive and we
want to have strong goals the next thing
you got to think about when you're going
through the job search is how do I
celebrate small ends right and here's
just the truth of the matter the truth
of the matter is that the job search is
pretty brutal there's a lot of non
responses there's a lot of ghosting
that's happening out out in the job
search world is something we hear almost
every day from job seekers and so what
you have to do is not let those little
those little like frustrations take over
your entire emotional state during the
job search you have to really dig out
those wins dig out those little positive
things whether it's just sending off a
networking email maybe you don't hear
back but the fact that you're sending
off that networking email you're
reaching out to someone you are trying
to build your network means that you are
becoming the type of person who is
building a successful career trajectory
right you are becoming the type of
person who networks who provides value
who can get jobs even if they don't
respond it's the activity that matters
not necessarily the outcome and then
once we are good at the activity we can
increase it increase it increase it
until it's a numbers game and you start
getting opportunities coming your way so
let's celebrate small wins you know
applying to three jobs in a day small
and give yourself some sort of
celebration maybe yeah for maybe like a
Reese's Peanut Butter Cup or something
if if you're reaching out to people give
yourself a pat on the back if you
finally met someone for coffee you know
really like you know give yourself a
smoothie or something on the way home
you know celebrate those little wins
because it's going to keep you motivated
throughout the search then that brings
us to our next point which is practicing
empathy a lot of times when you're going
through the job search it's frustrating
like I said there's a lot of
non-response there's a lot of ghosting
there's a lot of hey we'll get back to
you on Friday and they never get back
until two weeks later it happens this is
just how it is the hiring process is not
very efficient
let's just put it that way and so as
you're going through the hiring as
you're going through the job search you
got to realize that the folks you're
interacting with aren't necessarily
full-time hiring people they have other
jobs they are doing other things you
know they're trying to hit their
deadlines they're trying to get all
their calls and they're trying to meet
with their managers and they're trying
to support their employees and all these
different things right and so when
you're applying you've got to realize
that they have a flood of people that
they're trying to get through maybe
fifty a hundred hundreds even and so
they're not going to be able to get back
to everyone that's why this ghosting
happens that's why these non responses
happen it's just too hard to get back to
everyone and so we need to have a little
bit of empathy for the people that we're
dealing with and what this helps us do
is not take things so personally not
everything is a slight not everything
isn't it
not every non-response is telling you
that you're a failure and not cut for
the job cut out for the job sometimes
it's just bad communication so if we can
have a little more empathy for others we
can actually have a little bit more
positivity and a little bit more self
care for ourselves so those are the
things that you want to keep in mind and
then finally when you are feeling down
seek out support now I don't think this
is a big issue for this group because
you're all doing that right now you're
seeking out support by joining this
YouTube live but how else are you
seeking out support do you have friends
do have family do you have maybe a job
search group that you go to have you
been to meetup calm and checked out any
of their little support groups have you
joined the slack channels and talked to
other people and helped other people out
what are you doing to stay connected and
not feel so isolated and alone during
your job search because that's really
the big thing is most of most people who
are searching for a job
feel very alone they feel like all the
negativity all the non-response all the
rejection they feel like they're the
only one experiencing those things when
in reality a lot of people are
experiencing those things almost
everyone so you're not alone and if you
just take some time to reach out to
folks they'll be appreciative as well
because they want to feel less alone so
I hope that you'll do those things have
a plan celebrate wins practice empathy
and seek out support when you can and if
you are part of our if you if you're a
recent registrant
the nanodegree there is career coaching
that I believe is available some of the
new folks so take a look at that if you
go to your career portal you'll see your
eligibility there so might be a good
thing to check out and see if you can
get some one-on-one support as well all
right we've got some great questions
coming in here if you do have more
questions please put them in the chat
Karen is going to be sending them over
my way and I'll be digging through them
throughout the conversation here so do
not hesitate to hit enter and send us
that question
also I don't think most I don't really
believe in silly questions here so thank
you gem but I I actually think you ask a
great question and so don't feel like
your questions too silly to post we will
do our best to give a well rounded
answer to anything that's on your mind
okay Omar Omar asks how long does it
take on average to find a job this is a
very big hot-button question right this
is the thing that we all want to know
and we want to know it because we want
to think like oh well if the average is
this then that's just gonna happen for
me as well maybe I just need to be
patient right well it the first thing
I'm gonna say in response to this is
that the speed with which you get a job
is entirely correlated to the amount of
work you're putting in if you're only
applying to a couple of jobs a week only
spending a few hours a week doing the
job search your search might take up to
a year or more and I've seen this happen
to people where they think they're doing
enough but they're really not they're
not networking they're not reaching out
to people they're not building up their
skillset they're just going to the job
boards a couple times a week and hitting
easy apply and if you're doing that it
could be a very long time if you are
really immersing yourself into your
community and into the topics that
you're interested in your networking
multiple times a week you are reaching
out to people you are going to meetups
you are hosting meetups you are finding
ways to get internal referrals to
companies because 80% of jobs are found
through people that you know not through
job boards if you're doing all those
things on a regular basis and you're
consistent I mean it could be much
quicker I like to think that the
averages just sort of rule of thumb wise
I don't think this is totally backed up
by data but I'm sure some I've seen some
data that backs us up to a degree but
about like three months to six months is
the average amount of time it takes to
get a job
and that again depends on the amount of
work you're putting in but usually
around the six-month period people have
learned from their mistakes have figured
out what to do and have adapted their
job search in order to really get where
they want to get now they are also
putting in the work they're actually
analyzing the results they're saying hey
I've been doing this over and over and
over again for three months and I've
gotten no jobs out of it so maybe I need
to change something right maybe I need
to fix my approach here a little bit and
they've reached out to you know career
coaches they've joined job boards
they've you know done their research on
the muse or whatever research that
you're doing out there on the balance
comm or something like that and that's
how you really increase the speed of
your search increase the or get your
goals quicker so I would say typically
I'll save three to six months a year if
you're really going the bare minimum
with things but it's really all up to
you how much effort are you putting in
how much time are you dedicating to it
if you're dedicating a lot of time to it
and you're dedicating the time to the
right things like networking and
reaching out to people it could be much
faster thank you for your question is a
really good one all right
gem Chang asks I think my issue is I
keep learning and avoid starting my job
search how do I start my first step
thank you for this question this is a
great one and it actually hits on
something that I have a lot of I've had
a lot of folks do this and it's
something that I find really interesting
and a really interesting thing not just
for the job search but just like
people's lives in general I like to call
it productive procrastination now
learning new things and going to school
and getting more education and getting
certifications and all these different
things are wonderful right they help you
learn they help you grow they help you
expand your knowledge and your horizons
however they are not the work they are
not the job search and as you've very
aptly pointed out here you're using it
as a way to avoid
doing what you need you're using it as a
way to avoid doing what you know you
need to do if you have that realization
or if you're maybe concerned that you're
falling into that trap take a step back
and say do I need to learn this right
now or do I need to be applying to jobs
right now or do I need to be networking
right now where am I at in the search
because there is a time and a place for
learning and a time and a place for
outreach and time and a place for
applications and a time and a place to
start your job so I like to call a
productive procrastination it's what
people do when they're like I don't like
my job I don't know what I want to do
next so I'm just gonna go get a masters
degree all right now you're a hundred
thousand dollars in debt and the
master's degree does not guarantee that
you're going to know what you want to do
when you come out so suddenly you've
just productively procrastinated your
way into debt and you're no more clearer
on your career so what I would recommend
for those folks is to maybe put a pause
on going back to school and spend a
little more time trying to figure out
exactly what they enjoy and what they're
good at and where those things overlap
and what people need and go out and see
if they can do like a minimum viable
project let's say a minimum viable
project can I just do like some
internships or some little work on the
side maybe find a couple small
businesses to help and see if this is
actually what I want before I go learn
new things and so I Eveleigh promote
action over education even though they
supplement each other and there's a time
and a place for education and action to
to sort of work in tandem but if you
you've pointed out that you feel like
you're using it as a way to avoid
starting your job search
alright here's your first step your
first step is to say what are all the
things I need to do to get a job I need
to build my network I need to figure out
what my goals are I need to start
reaching out to people and then I need
to apply to things so I think the first
thing the first step to getting out of
the education trap is to say what is it
that I really want to do what job title
do I really want to have look up a bunch
of job listings download their
you know copy and paste pull out the
things that you think are the most
interesting pick the job title eat or
maybe three job titles you think are the
most interesting reach out to some
people who do those jobs ask them what
their job is like what is the day today
and you'll get some pretty good inside
information there and then you can say
that sounds great
do I have enough knowledge to apply to
those jobs if not maybe go grab another
certification whatever you need to do
then go get the job but a lot of times
you probably have enough enough
education and you can just start trying
to find an internship or some sort of
volunteer gig you know the best
education is real life education so I
highly recommend that all right Eamon
question is looking for a job or sorry
is looking for a job abroad a drawback
for me against other candidates I assume
that means that you're in a different
country trying to come to the u.s. or
maybe you're in the u.s. trying to go to
a different country I wish I had a
little bit more information on it but I
guess let's dig into what you're really
asking here is it a drawback against
other candidates potentially if they're
in the area and they can meet people in
person that gives them a leg up but the
nice thing is that most people aren't
networking and aren't reaching out in
person so it's only a drawback if you
think about it as a drawback if you
think about it as an opportunity for you
to reach out to people you can really
use it to your advantage one of the
great things about moving to a new
location is that when you reach out to
people you don't have to be like hey I
want a job can you give me a job like if
I'm trying to meet some of the Chicago
and they you know know I'm a job seeker
like well what do you what do you want
to talk about no I guess I just want to
talk about the job right but if you're
moving to a new area you can ask
questions about everything what's the
area like what's the job market like
what do you like about working there why
do you live here why did you choose to
move to this place you really get to
have a really interesting conversation
with these folks that goes beyond just
the job that you want so it could be a
very very good way for you to reach out
to people and say hey let's say I'll
just give the example when I moved to
Texas years back I just reached out to
people who were doing jobs that I
thought were interesting and I said hey
I'm moving to Texas in three months I'm
really curious about the job market
there and I'm also really curious about
like what what you enjoy about Texas
would you be open for a Skype call or
coffee when I get into town most people
said yes so then when I would get
together with them I'd be like what's
your favorite coffee shop where do you
like to eat where's the best taco in
town what is the job market like here
what are the cool places to visit what
are the great bars you know all those
interesting things so it becomes much
more of a conversation rather than like
an interrogation to see if they have a
job that you can do and if you approach
it from that perspective ask for their
advice what they like you know you're
gonna have some really interesting
conversations and get some really good
connections in this new place that
you're trying to move so I don't think
it's a drawback I think you just need to
approach it the right way and dig into
your curiosity what is it about this new
area that you're moving that you're so
curious about all right awesome great
question thank you for asking it all
right we have a question here
anetha krishna i'm a student now and to
graduate later this year should i I'm a
student now and I'm going to graduate
later this year should I start my job
search or wait until I graduate question
about timing I love it
in my opinion you should never ever wait
because what are you waiting for
do you have time in your schedule right
now to start doing something that helps
get your job search rolling can you
start networking maybe get a coffee or
two a week can you put your application
materials together and include things
that you know you'll have skills you
know you'll have once you graduate can
you improve your online presence
everyone can improve their online
presence your LinkedIn your website your
I don't YouTube Instagram Twitter
whatever it is that you're using to
promote yourself online I believe that
your job search should always be
something that you're somewhat working
on at all times and and what I mean by
that is like your personal brand is
something that you should be working on
at all times you should always be
meeting new people in your field you
should always be tweaking things and
making sure your stuffs up to dates you
don't have to do you know a ten year
backlog update of everything all at once
right if you do things in small
increments over time it's much easier to
keep things updated keep things fresh so
I personally think you should absolutely
start the job search now maybe you're
not you don't need to start applying to
everything but you can get all your
materials ready you can get your network
started you can start volunteering for
organizations you can start joining
professional groups you can start going
to meet ups you can start
joining different threads on reddit and
Cora and different slack channels
there's a lot of cool things that you
can do so don't wait get started now
because otherwise you're gonna get to
graduation go oh no now I have nothing
no structure to my day nothing keeping
me focused and you're gonna get
overwhelmed so I think having
getting started while you have some
structure is always a good way to go
there's one more thing I wanted to add
here Oh a lot of times folks will take a
vacation after they finish some sort of
learning some sort of educational
certification or they'll like they'll
finish their course and they'll say ah
yes I'm out of that stressful course I'm
gonna take three weeks or or one week or
a month off and and I'm just gonna
travel or go sit on the beach somewhere
and then when I get back I'll start my
search I got to tell ya the folks that
decide to do that tend to be the ones
that have the hardest time getting
started with their job search because
they go from incredibly busy to
incredibly lazy and then they have to
dig themselves back out of that hole to
get back to like some level of
productivity and they have no structure
they're starting to stress out about
money and all sorts of other things
start popping up so I do not encourage
taking a break I mean if you're like
completely stressed out to the gills and
you need a mental health day go for it
but for the most part people that take
breaks tend to fall off it's like it's
like taking a break from working out
yeah all of a sudden a month goes by and
you haven't been to the gym so just keep
that in mind as you're thinking about
your next steps thank you for your
question very good one all right
Shubin I have graduated last year I have
some skills in data science so is it
better to apply for a job with my skill
set or should I apply to jobs that have
skills that I'm still learning hmm
this is a really good one I guess it
depends it depends on what your goals
are you said you have some skills in
data science and so my assumption here
is that bad slope that's what you would
want I guess I'm a little confused on
the question are you saying that you
have the data science skills already and
you you are trying to decide whether or
not to apply to a data science job or to
a different job that you need more
skills to get or that you're still
getting your data science skills and you
want to apply to something else and then
maybe later apply today at the data
science if you could just comment a
little bit more context on this one in
the comments but I'll try to tackle what
your question is here so when you're
thinking about your career what do you
want to be doing you know a few years
down the line a lot of us here or I mean
everyone here who's taken a nano degree
has invested money and time into a
specific skillset that they want to
learn typically because you want to turn
that skillset into a part of or your
full-time job so if you learned a new
skill in order to be able to move in
that direction I think it's pretty good
to start trying to find opportunities
that relate to the thing that you want
to be doing long-term now if you need to
get a job in the mean time just to get
some income and keep your financials in
order I see no problem with that you
know keep yourself stable as you're
trying to find the long term strategy
right but if if if you're learning data
science you just don't really feel up to
snuff and you're worried about applying
to things and getting rejected the truth
of matter is is that everyone who's
applying to everything feels a little
bit like
I don't know if I'm gonna get this
that's why they're applying right so it
really doesn't matter how much like what
out what I find is no matter how much
people know no matter how many skills
they acquire no matter how many tests
they pass and how many apps they've
built they always feel like they don't
know enough they always feel like
there's more to learn which is a great
thing because it keeps us motivated
however we got to get past that little
mental block and start applying to
things that we want so if you think you
get an internship it with the skill set
that you currently have that moves you
in the direction of the job that you
want go for it do you think you can
volunteer for something if you think you
can take on a small part-time project go
for it and then if you need another job
to sort of build your income in the
meantime I see that that is a good thing
as well so I hope that answers your
question if you have more context and
you want to dig a little deeper please
put in the chat Karen will send it over
to me and we can dig in a little deeper
before the end of the call all right
Rachel thank you so much for your
question what questions do you recommend
asking when an interviewer asks you what
questions you have for them all right
let me they get it's a bit of a tongue
twister what questions do you recommend
asking when the interviewer asks what
questions you have for them so we just
made a video about this last week it was
our 21st career tip it was what
questions to ask at the end of the
interview and I think I gave a handful
of examples but this is an awesome
question because it's incredibly
important to think about the mindset
you're bringing into your interview when
you're and these questions will will
sort of show what you're thinking about
the most a lot of times at the end of an
interview people who aren't well versed
in interviewing will ask very basic
questions that are a bit selfish if you
think about them and much more focus on
you then the collaboration of you and
them creating this role because that's
really at the end of the day like you
are creating this role with them so we
need to keep the
mind so there should be questions that
you have about the industry about the
job about how you're being measured and
so on and we'll get into that in a
second but the real thing is like when
you're when you get to the end of the
interview if you if you ask a question
about like how much time do we get off
for vacation and sick leave or if you
ask a question like you know what is the
Learning stipend in this role you know
those things are going to be discussed
when you get the offer like you'll get a
packet that that breaks all those
details down first of all they're very
like concise answers I can answer with
well you have seven days or twenty days
or whatever the thing is and it doesn't
help build the conversation it kind of
ends on a weird note where you're like
can you satisfy my needs right when
you're in an interview you want to be
helpful you want to be saying like what
is that that they need what is it that
they're struggling with what is it that
they're excited about what is it that
they are looking for in a candidate and
how can I help make them feel
comfortable and confident that I'm the
right person for the role so some good
things to ask what skills made the last
person who did this role really
successful and what traits did they have
that made them not as successful as you
would have liked what would you say what
would you say success looks like in this
job maybe three months from now six
months from now how will this role be
how well success in this role be
measured right what are some of the
things that the company's trying to work
on right now that are still in like
early stage development like where do
you see the company going in the future
how do you see how do you see the
products that we're creating right now
becoming part of the industry zeitgeist
as we go forward there's a lot of
questions you can ask about like the
interviewers interest in things like
what is it you know you find to be the
best part
your job like what do you enjoy the most
you can get them talking about things
that they're interested in or their
opinions on things and and really what
you want to do is be like hey you know
what is it something what is something
that you're trying to achieve in the
next six months that you're that you're
like kind of you know trying to get off
the ground right now and the Vic oh
we're trying to launch this big thing
and you'll be like how would my role be
able to help out with that and now
you're like helping them come up with
solutions to their problems right you
are now a consultant for them now there
is a ton of amazing resources online so
if you just google best questions to ask
at the end of an interview you're gonna
get all sorts of great knowledge there
maybe even too much a little
overwhelming but try when you're reading
through the list be be discerning say
like when you're reading things be like
how would that actually go in
conversation if I were to ask that is it
is it a question that opens up the
conversation and makes it easier for us
to talk to each other or is a question
that kind of you know we'll have a
one-word answer or a yes-or-no answer or
a like why are they asking me this
answer so I hope that gives you a little
bit of direction on where to go with
those questions make it more about them
make it more about how you can be
successful in this role and you can say
like you know are there any things that
we didn't get to cover that you're still
curious about with my experience and you
can give more context there so hopefully
that gives a little more context and
will help set you up for success in your
next interview all right Omar
do you think it's a good idea to contact
people who work at companies you want to
work for through social media this is a
really good one all right
so how do you reach out to people and
where do you reach out to people and
what is social media right what
constitutes social media is LinkedIn
social media that's where a lot of
people are reaching out so the short
answer is yes I think it's a great idea
the long answer is there's certain ones
that I use and I'm really good at and
there's certain ones I don't use and I'm
not that great at Twitter seems to be a
pretty big hotbed for jobs and a lot of
people use it to connect with people DM
for opportunities chat just live you
know and and a lot of companies will
post their job postings on Twitter so if
you're on Twitter and you like Twitter I
would absolutely engage on Twitter
because people are getting jobs on
Twitter all the time Instagram also an
interesting one maybe not as active as
Twitter but depending on what you're
trying to do whether it's like digital
marketing social media art I know a lot
of artists that use a that use Instagram
to network and do different things I
think it's a strong tool for networking
as well and show maybe showcasing your
interest showcasing your product
projects Instagram might be a little bit
more of a branding tool than a
communication tool but I still think I'm
sure there's job listings on Instagram
that are worth exploring more on Twitter
but definitely some on Instagram
LinkedIn huge huge huge place to
obviously apply to jobs we're all
playing on LinkedIn that's where
everyone goes but also just to connect
and network with people and communicate
right so when you go to LinkedIn try and
do a reverse people search and if you
google Martin McGovern you tube reverse
people search a long search query I have
a video that will show you exactly how
to use the filters exactly how to find
people
and you can use that in order to find
people who do the job that you wish you
were doing connect with them and learn
from them and ask their advice on how to
get a job so another thing I like to do
and I think email is still the strongest
way to reach out to people is use that
use the results from LinkedIn or
Instagram or Twitter whatever you're
using to identify the people you want to
connect with and if you want to reach
out personally and set up a one-on-one
coffee which is called an informational
interview and it's something I recommend
everyone does what you can do is you can
use websites like WWF find that email to
find these people's email addresses and
reach out to them personally and say hey
it looks like you're doing some
interesting things in this industry
would love to grab coffee and you know
hear about your experiences and how you
got into the work that you're doing and
what you like about it would you be open
to chatting and usually that sets up
some really good conversations and so
there's a lot of different ways to reach
out to people in a lot of different
places I haven't even mentioned you know
reddit has job listings and Craigslist
has job listings a little sketchier
right I even know someone who found a
networking group through his clash of
clans like slack chat so you know you
never know I would use it as many things
to your advantage as you can that you're
comfortable using like you know I'm not
comfortable with Twitter it's just never
been my forte
but if I really wanted to find jobs and
get get in that area I I would go learn
it because that's a that's definitely a
place where people are finding things
all right our next question is from
Diego and it's about finances
he says I'm a little worried about
earning less money than I currently do
if I start a new data science machine
learning career I'm working full-time as
a full-stack software engineer right now
let me reread that with correct
enunciation I'm a little worried about
earning less money than I currently do
if I start a new data science machine
learning career I'm working full-time as
a full-stack and software engineer right
now Diego this is a huge huge part of
the job search that is not talked about
enough the financial side
what is your runway what level of risk
are you willing to tolerate what are you
willing to change in order to achieve
the things that you want to achieve if
you actually are going to need to take a
pay cut to change industries you might
also need to take a look at how you're
living your life and how you're spending
money and where your lifestyle is at and
adjust it accordingly and this is a big
ask like you know it's not my place to
say what you should do with your life
right but job career changes are risky
right and but so is staying in a job
that you don't want to be in right so
you got to kind of take a step back say
where are my app financially if you're
not ready financially to make a huge
career change right now and you don't
want to take on the debt and you don't
want to do those things you can ask
yourself okay
when can I how much do I need to save in
order to be able to make that transition
what and during that time maybe it takes
a year two years to save up enough money
to make that career transition so that
you can actually live solidly while
you're starting up and ramping up in
this new gig then you can say alright
I've saved money for that time and
during that time I'm also building my
data science skills right I'm learning
how to be a machine learning how to
build a machine learning career
so you're keeping the security while
building this up to eclipse it and
that's one of my favorite things about
side hustles and different things that
people do they keep doing what they're
doing until the thing that they're doing
on the side eclipses it it's actually
something I did I was working in
marketing and then I started coaching
and then coaching slowly took over the
marketing and the marketing went down a
little bit so see what you can do in
addition to your job so keep your job
see if you can pick up some side work
pick up some contract work as a data
science and machine learning person and
then as you're building that on the side
now you have two streams of income and
then someday maybe the second stream of
income can get close enough to your main
stream of income that you can do a
smaller dip rather than a big drop
that's a safe way to do it and I I
definitely don't I don't know I've been
a risky person in my life but I've also
not had you know my own family or
something to support while I've made
these risky moves I've done big shifts
like you know taking six months to
figure things out and build up my own
thing and those while they are very
risky and you know take some time to
come back from it
depending on how quickly you want to get
things done it could be the right way to
go depending on how how open you are to
risk it could be the right way to go but
I think for the majority of people I
don't think the majority of the world is
very risk of is is very like risk
tolerant I think most people want a
pretty steady plan for their life and so
I would say yeah try and build it on the
side and see what you can build as you
slowly allow it to eclipse your current
role if you have any other questions
around that please bring them up I I'm
sure that's like hotly debated I'm sure
there's a lot of different strategies
that we can bring into that concept and
find other ways to approach it as well
but thank
question Diego
[Music]
question is from a Kanak I'm so sorry
I'm terrible at pronouncing names if
anyone has resources of how to pronounce
names that would be very helpful but the
question is how can I stay positive and
confident while I've received a job
description from a recruiter which is
aligned with my profile but is giving me
way too big a hike in responsibility or
skills my head is just telling me that
it's out of my ability and I won't be
able to do it this is a really
interesting question thank you so much
for this question gosh there's a lot of
different ways we can go with this the
first thing that pops in my head is are
you really truly not ready for this role
because a lot of times when people like
when recruiters reach out and have
looked at your profile I've looked at
your experience like we assume that the
people who are doing the job are these
experts these amazing people who know
everything and can solve stuff with
their eyes closed you know when in
reality once you get into most jobs
most people are winging it most people
are just doing their best most people
are googling stuff constantly and trying
to figure things out
most people don't feel like they're
qualified for the role that they're in
that's why impostor syndrome is a real
thing so that's the first thing I'm
going to call out art are you truly not
qualified or is this impostor syndrome
getting in your head and making you feel
like you're not ready the second thing I
would say is if you truly aren't ready
like you've looked at the Job
Description you only have 20 to 40% of
the stuff that's on there then maybe
have a conversation with the recruiter
and say hey I really love that you
reached out to me about this opportunity
I actually think I might be I might need
to do the non senior role or I might
need to do the junior level role or I
might be a better fit for the junior
level role and you can just have that
conversation and say like what do you
think like
do you think there's any junior level
roles that I could apply poor I think
they'd definitely better align with my
experience and this is something you
could probably see with like people who
are trying to be managers for the first
time some people really want to be
managers some people don't and you can
sort of see like well maybe I had all
these skills but I just wasn't ready for
that piece so number one is it is it
true or is it impostor syndrome and
number two if it is true just have a
conversation with the recruiter and let
them know that you think maybe a junior
or a non senior role would be the better
way to go the next thing is let's say it
is just impostor syndrome
and how do you stay positive and
confident when you're feeling not so
positive and not so confident that's
just gonna be a real practice in sitting
down and looking through your past what
are the things that you've done up to
this point that you can like look at and
say you know I was nervous when I
started the nanodegree but I finished it
I was nervous when I had this other job
but I did well in it I was nervous when
I went to college but I graduated I was
nervous when XYZ all the different
things in your life because typically
our mind if we're you know anxious we
like to focus on the negative things
that have happened in our life and we
downplay the positive so this goes back
to my advice at the beginning of how to
stay motivated which is celebrate little
wins I bet that there are a ton of
positive things that you do a ton of
positive work that you've done a ton of
really great experience that you have
that you might not be giving yourself
credit for and celebrating so maybe sit
down and just try and look back and say
you know I did do these things well and
that could help you stay positive and
confident as you're having these
conversations and I think it's perfectly
fine to be honest with a recruiter it's
very easy to be honest with a recruiter
much easier be honest of the recruiter
then you know person works at the
company because recruiters have multiple
opportunities that they're dealing with
so who knows they might have something
that fits you better hope that helps all
right we've got ten minutes left so I'm
gonna try and get through as many
questions but we've got a great turnout
today with a lot of really awesome
questions so trying to squeeze them all
in as quickly as I can I appreciate I
appreciate everyone who shared I
apologize if I don't get to everything
all right our next question from Krish
what should I do when I'm getting
repeatedly rejected and my interviewers
don't give feedback I love this this is
a great question because the first thing
that stands out to me is that you think
getting repeatedly rejected is unusual
you think you you maybe think I'm making
some assumptions here but I'm making
them base off the coaching calls and
conversations that I typically have on a
daily basis typically people think that
getting rejected is like a real like
staple it's like this is solid you've
been rejected right when in reality it's
incredibly common to get rejected it's
incredibly common for people to just go
stand not respond it's incredibly common
for it to take three to six months to
get a job it is incredibly common all
these things that like when we're in our
own job search when we're in our own
head when we can't see everyone else
who's applying for jobs and getting
rejected and having their own little
mental breakdowns we we think we're the
only one experiencing rejection when in
reality everyone is experiencing
rejection and the thing that we need to
keep coming back to is that we don't
need other people to tell us why we
didn't get the job we can sit down and
look at our materials and say where can
I improve
the Job Description reflect back on the
conversations you had if you got to the
interview process look at your resume
look at your online presence we can all
do more are you engaging on LinkedIn are
you getting internal referrals are you
networking are you doing all of the
things that you need to do if you're
just applying to the job boards which
99% of people that's all they do you
better get used to rejection because you
can the job boards really only have like
a 1 to 4 percent response rate and so if
that's all we're doing that's a pretty
high rejection rate that we're gonna be
dealing with so I highly recommend maybe
just taking a step back you know what
should I do when I'm getting repeatedly
rejected I'm not getting feedback take a
step back give your self feedback do an
audit of your own stuff if other people
won't tell you do an audit of your own
stuff reach out to a career coach reach
out to a friend have someone else look
at it to who will give you feedback and
then remember that rejection is normal
and that when you're getting rejected I
actually like to look at it as a
positive because it means that I'm
applying to things to have no rejections
means I'm not actually trying to get a
job so if you're getting rejected it
means that you're actually sending out
applications and I applaud you for that
because it's tough to get your stuff
together and start sending it out so I
really would like you to keep that in
mind and just remember when you're
getting rejections just take the energy
that you would use being frustrated and
put it back into creating an even better
application for the next job
all right our next question is from tech
controversy how do I explain a story of
recent job hunt sorry how do I explain a
story of a can't read today how do I
explain a story of recent job hopping
applying for a third position in a
period of two years when the two
previous positions were a bad fit this
is a really interesting question thank
you I'm really curious to know what you
mean by a bad fit was it the work that
you are doing or the manager that you
were working with or the team that you
were on or the company or the pay what
what do you mean by a bad fit and gosh
I'm I have so many questions but being a
job hopper is fairly normal in our world
today it used to be that people would
stay at a job for like 10 to 15 years
whereas I believe the average the recent
average on job hopping is like on
average people change jobs in the tech
field every two to four years so having
three jobs in a two year period isn't as
weird as it used to be now with that
said how do you explain it
well it's gonna really rely on what the
reasons for the hops were were you
hopping for more money were you hopping
for to better align with the skills that
you want it to be practicing every day
were you hopping because of a new team
were you running away from things or
running towards things I think a lot of
times we focus on what we're running
away from oh I had a bad manager or oh
that project was really hard or whatever
the thing might be but what were you
running to if you can tell the story
from what you were running to oh I
wanted to get involved with self-driving
cars oh I wanted to learn a new tech
stack oh I wanted to get experience in
advertising if you can explain what you
were running towards that's a really
positive way to show that you needed to
make a few changes and you didn't want
to you know waste the company's time
you know paying you for something you
didn't want to be doing so you figured
out what you wanted to be doing you went
after it now at a certain point it's
probably good to spend more than a year
at a company but yeah I think it's one
of those things where look at the
positive look at the the positive reason
that you moved and then you really only
have to talk about it if they care a lot
of companies don't care so much anymore
but if they bring it up just say like I
wanted to learn this thing or I wanted
to do this thing or I wanted to work
with these people and that's a perfectly
valid reason to change jobs and in the
tech industry that we live in gosh we
are coming way close to the end here I
apologize I'm not gonna be able to get
to everyone's questions I wonder if
there's a short one I can dig into
before we wrap up today
all right Sanjay should I give my best
in my current job which I don't like and
want to switch out of please answer
alright Sanjay we're gonna end on your
question should you give your best in
your current job I mean the short answer
is yes you should always be doing the
best job that you possibly can now
obviously motivation fluctuates over
time and sometimes you're really gung-ho
and you're really energetic and you're
working weekends and you're and you're
like you know lovin every second of it
and sometimes you're just working the
40-hour week and you're getting through
it and you're doing your job fine
everyone's have a different place in
their career the question I have that's
actually more important than should I do
my best because I mean the obvious
answer is yes you should do your best
you should never be purposefully or
willingly doing a bad job but are you
making time for your job search if you
know you want to leave if you know this
job's not right for you are you making
time to at night and on the weekends
meet people Network search for a job
figure out what you want to do next do
the internal exploration get your
profiles up to date all those things
that you need to do to get the next job
are you doing those things or you're
just kind of wallowing are you wallowing
and complaining and and you know sitting
in that lack of motivation so should you
do your best in your current job I do
believe you should if you want to switch
jobs start putting in the work now don't
don't spend all your time nights and
weekends working on a job that you don't
like carve out some time for yourself
this is your life these are your hours
so make sure that you're making time to
figure out what's next and move towards
it alright that was an awesome Q&A today
thank you everyone who came out and
joined us it was really fun digging into
your questions I'm sorry we didn't get
into everything this has been asked a
career coach we do these every single
Thursday so please jump into the link in
the chat and sign up for the next one
it'll be next week Thursday same time
same place YouTube live I'll be here
answering your questions I appreciate
all of you for come
now I appreciate all of you for
returning those who have been joining us
along this journey of answering
questions and
we're pretty me on LinkedIn or shoot me
a slack or an email however you want to
get in touch I'm pretty open to it and
I'll help answer any questions that I
can in order to help you succeed in your
search thanks again and have a great
rest of the week